search for missing five year old girl is
intensifying today after her mother
stopped cooperating with police an Amber
Alert was issued after Taylor Williams
was reported missing Wednesday in
Jacksonville Florida but investigators
say it's been weeks and she was last
seen
Mireya Villarreal is outside of her home
in Jacksonville Florida right now Maria
good morning to you does it does this
mean that investigators are now focusing
on the mother
well good morning Gail right now the
sheriff is telling us that they are
exploring every possibility Briana
William said when she woke up Wednesday
morning her daughter was gone but the
sheriff is now saying there are some
inconsistencies in her story search
teams have knocked on more than 600
doors looking inside dumpsters and
divers scouring a nearby lake hoping to
find five year-old Taylor Williams
I feel bad and that's our job you know
you know didn't help find this little
girl and while nothing substantial has
been found volunteers say they don't
want to give up until they find out what
happened to her
we know that breanna williams was the
last person to see taylor and we need
for her to cooperate sheriff mike
williams says Taylor's mom Brianna was
initially working with police but is now
no longer cooperating we were talking to
her about some inconsistencies in her
statement and that's when she chose to
stop cooperating with us the young
girl's mother reportedly told police
when she woke up Wednesday morning
Taylor wasn't in her bedroom and the
back door was open but sheriff Williams
says investigators do not believe the
five year old walked away from the home
law enforcement curtailed search efforts
Thursday evening over the weekend
Taylor's family moved out of this
apartment complex
Tiffany nicole says she helped them
Sunday the whole 45 minutes we were
there loading things up I never once saw
a child is strange cuz I'm like I didn't
even know she had a little girl
investigators are asking anyone who's
seen Taylor with her mother in the area
in the last six months to call police so
we remain hopeful that we'll find Taylor
we're not gonna stop in our efforts to
locate her
Briona williams is a petty officer
stationed with the Navy here in
Jacksonville but most of her family is
in Alabama and that's why Florida
authorities are working with law
enforcement in Alabama right now as well
the Florida Crimestoppers they are
offering a reward for anybody that has
information on where Taylor is Tony
deepening mystery there Marea thank you
very much